is the new 16-in M3 Pro MacBook Pro
actually worth it over the 14in model
well they both got the same M3 Pro chip
except with the 16-in you're forced into
upgrading to the 12 core CPU and 18 core
GPU which ends up costing $500 more
compared to the base 14-in model for
$2,000 with the bend chip so before I
get into the real world performance
differences I want to give you guys a
good idea of the differences in size
portability and other things like the
speakers and displays in terms of the
actual footprint you can see just how
much bigger the 16-in model is which
instantly makes it more difficult to fit
into a backpack or bag and even just
carrying it in your hands becomes a bit
more challenging especially due to the
extra 1.3 lb of weight up to 4.8 lb and
on top of that it's also quite a bit
thicker as well and that's mostly due to
the fact that you can get a much bigger
battery and a larger cooling system
overall which helps reduce fan noise as
I'll discuss later in the performance
section so in terms of the design and
portability the 14-in MacBook Pro is the
Clear Choice if you really care about
being able to take it with you all the
time and you get the added benefit of
saving $500 and choosing whether you
want to upgrade to the 12 core M3 Pro
variant as far as the ports and
connectivity they're identical between
the two models with the same three
Thunderbolt 4 ports HDMI and SD card
slot but one thing that's different is
actually the speakers because the 16-in
model has larger speaker enclosures so
let's do a quick speaker
[Music]
comparison as you just heard the 16in
gets noticeably louder in the mids as
well as having much more base so that's
an added little bonus for those who love
using their laptops to listen to music
or watch stuff the 16in also has a much
larger trackpad which can be quite handy
giving you more room for gestures and
whatever else but apart from that
there's really nothing else different
design-wise now as far as the webcams
and microphones they should be identical
on both of these 1080p quality and they
should sound pretty nice as well but the
benefit for the 16-inch model is that
the webcam is actually higher because of
the display size so you get a little bit
of a higher angle which does look better
so that's an interesting difference and
now moving on to the displays the 16-in
model is noticeably larger giving you a
bit more screen real estate to work with
so it's a bit easier to multitask and
split screen as well as for editing
videos photos and whatever else and on
top of that it makes it so much better
if you plan to watch movies on your
MacBook or especially gaming with a
larger display
this right here is the number one reason
why I personally bought a 16-in M1 Max
Model A couple years back and I love it
but one thing many people don't know is
that the resolution is actually quite a
lot higher on the 16-in model with 3.5k
resolution instead of 3K on the 14in so
you don't have to sacrifice pixel
density and another difference most
people don't think about is that while
the camera Notch is the same size in
both the 14 and 16-in model
as well as the thickness of the bezels
being the same both the Notch and the
bezels seem a lot smaller or Slimmer due
to the larger display and you can
actually fit more apps in the menu bar
on the 16in as well due to the extra
screen width with that said let's get
into the performance testing so here are
the specs on the screen so you can see
the differences once again before we
begin but first I want to show you guys
the perfect external monitor for your
Mac MacBook Pro or any Mac you might
have from our sponsor Ben Q This is
their 27in 4K 16x9 designer monitor that
seamlessly integrates with Max with just
a single USBC cable that transmits video
audio and data while also providing 90
WS of power delivery to keep your
macbook's battery topped up it's also
got excellent Cable Management with
their unique Ergo arm stand which
basically clamps down on the back of
your desk providing a clean desk setup
and a ton of adjustability like swivel
and height adjustment pivoting and
tilting even better benq's AQ color
technology produces the most color
accurate images with uniformity Tex so
the color and brightness is consistent
across the entire monitor while
supporting 95% P3 color gamut and out of
the-box color accuracy of less than
three Delta e so order today to get a
10% discount on benq's PD 2706 UA Ergo
arm monitor by clicking the link in the
description and pin comment below with
the coupon code Tech pd10 starting off
with performance in geekbench 6 the
single core performance is just slightly
faster on the upgraded M3 Pro chip which
makes sense since the cores themselves
are the same but in multicore the
upgraded chip is giving us
14.4% more performance for25 5% more
cash which isn't really worth it on the
16-in model but keep in mind that you
can upgrade the chip on the 14in for
$300 by itself so that becomes only 15%
more cash so it's actually a decent
upgrade so far we also tested the
10-minute stress test in the new cinnam
bench 2024 and the 16in model scored
around 16.8% faster likely because of
the better cooling system with larger
fans and the larger chassis for better
Heat dissipation moving over to graphics
performance in geekbench 6 we're looking
at 14% faster but then in 3D Marks
Wildlife Extreme Gaming test the
upgraded M3 Pro is getting 20% more FPS
which is actually a killer upgrade for
gamers now we also tested web design
performance in figma using a test
project provided to us by 500 designs
one of the best design studios in
California we exported 12 layers in the
upgraded M3 Pro finished just 1 second
faster so there's no point at all to
upgrade the chip for web design we then
tested music production in logic pro and
the 16-in model was able to play 22%
more tracks at the same time without
overloading which is actually a pretty
great upgrade if you have that type of
workload now moving on to programming
performance in the xcode 15 Benchmark
the base 14-in MacBook Pro only took 10
seconds longer to complete this real
world task which honestly tells me it's
not worth upgrading for this type of
work since it's barely any faster and
then I tested real world photo editing
using Lightroom classic to export 50 raw
42 megapixel images and they ended up
finishing in exactly the same time 45
seconds once again there's no reason it
all to upgrade for this type of work
that uses the GPU to export photos so
then I tested 3D rendering and blender
4.0 beta which now supports Ray tracing
and the upgraded M3 Pro chip was only
2.5 seconds faster which was actually a
bit mindblowing but then it makes sense
because the rate tracing cores
themselves are identical on both
machines and that's what the limitation
is in this test so for 3D rendering
there's absolutely no reason to upgrade
to the better M3 Pro chip and now moving
on to video editing I exported a 5minute
4K project which uses the most common
format that people record in and edit
these days which is HC or
h.265 and lo and behold they both
finished in exactly 2 minutes and 20
seconds which is the speed of the hvc
encoders which once again is identical
on both of these machines so for most
people who edit video no difference at
all and finally I tested something that
isn't limited by the encoders and is
probably the toughest video cic out
there right now Canon R5 8K raw footage
which maxes out both the CPU and the GPU
at the same time the 16in model with the
upgraded M3 Pro Finish exactly 1 minute
faster which is a decent upgrade but the
bigger difference was the fan noise the
14in was almost maxing out the fans by
the end of the test averaging at
6,234 RPM compared to the 16in which was
a lot quieter at only an average of
3,168 RPM so that was a huge benefit of
the larger 16in size with the better
cooling system so with all of that said
and tested is it worth upgrading from
the base M3 Pro chip up to the upgraded
version which comes on the 16-in MacBook
Pro well in my opinion there are only a
couple of reasons to do so and honestly
all of those reasons have to do with the
16inch chassis itself and not the
upgraded chip because looking at
performance it's not really worth the
extra money just for the performance but
with the 16-in chassis you get the
larger display the larger trackpad the
better battery life the better cooling
system for Less fan noise the better
speakers basically all of the awesome
benefits come with the larger size and
not the chip upgrade so if you're
choosing just a 14-in MacBook Pro don't
upgrade the chip just keep at the base
$2,000 model and spend your money
somewhere else because the chip
difference was not good enough in my
opinion so the only reason you should be
buying the upgraded M3 Pro chip with 12
CPU cores and 18 GPU cores is if you're
just getting the 16in which already
comes with it so hopefully you guys
enjoy this video and if you did
subscribe above and check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next
video
he